haha back to back welcome to this video
I'm happily this guy just before so
let's see out for some revenge yeah well
revenge is wrong word but I'd like to
score of course in that game that I lost
the one before that um I basically
killed myself so it it wasn't yeah it's
not that there is need for revenge like
he won rookie against rookie more so it
was just a normal game where I and it
was forbidden awkward but he just beat
me fair fair and square when I butchered
up the opening okay what is he doing
there with beef I if he wants to play
maybe hmm k a wonder
okay that's that definitely not bad mmm
b5 that's a strange strange opening here
if he goes b5 I always have to vary a
little bit about my e for porn normal
good recipe against b5 is soft and just
play a 3 i'm not sure about this here
Quincy to I don't know if he that's not
probably okay I think if he goes before
night a form i will be able to yeah he
takes one yeah okay take all you can
take on f3 they're doubling my pawns but
not sure how bad this is can pre move it
though
it's also a concession if he takes on f3
giving me the the bishop CF and it's not
so clear that he manages to to play c5
here ok so if I go like a five and nine
a form on 94 immediately we can take
place five but still ok let's go nite a
for blocking c5 make it difficult for
him to play the move and he cannot just
play rook c8 for example I will take a
six the question is so if i should play
a five at some point like a five-night
goes back and then you might play f6 to
a check my advanced pawn maybe I should
have fell and started with that move now
that I look at it but it's this if I go
if five he goes back Quincy six isn't
this quite awkward for him I don't I
don't get it at the moment Quincy 6 i'm
attacking d7 and it has nowhere to go we
cannot play rook c8 or whatever ok yeah
that was the only move probably not to
lose some material straight away um is
he going for Roxy seven or something I
have Queen a six though
okay I can play a 3m night b8 might be a
move not be a then I go back to see two
queens 27 I had that still ok it's still
ok my thread is before him pushing him
back all the way
cooksey 7 i'd take a 698 Quincy to Luke
c7 quindi one okay all the way back but
I have before I 95 next and that's it
right look Steph that looks very
difficult for black and less I'm
overlooking something now his his piece
of CM e 8d 7e7 they all look awkward
maybe I had a better move than a three I
don't know but before it's really if I
get this in it he has to retreat the
Queen it's essentially over yeah and he
retreats voluntarily came so if I go if
I go before Luke c7 Queen 86 I still
don't see what the problem is actually
before before a five maybe
hmm
I can easily self trap your queen here
but this is slow the principal and let
me let's do that I can also act just
played Quincy too but I don't really see
how he activates Lucas is having Queen a
62 looks like it still looks very
convincing and the queen is irritating
him so ok at least I got a retreat out
of him let's say v f6 years hmm yeah I
guess just a phone I could have played
night c5 maybe but ok that's not not to
move that wow ok cheeky seven ok let's
take them now you might get this look
over to g7 of funky stuff like that ok
so night c5 now for attack on e6 or
fatigue Bishop takes mm-hmm it may be
threatened to check them
the other coming to g7 this is quite
awkward
okay I took me ages to find that move
but I still think it's good keeping
keeping things a little bit closed ok
let's go here yeah that was bad yeah
that it took me so long to play that
move I can't play 96 of course and maybe
I should do that 96 but no time on which
looks good run I'm attacking this and I
have still 96 in the back of those moves
ok I can take care for 96 right he has
no checks at the end there will be the
night on be eight
I was a shaky way to play I should have
done that much clearer and somehow but
that's I think it's good enough
somewhere I cannot give this check now
this check is going for Queenie seven
let's just art with that check maybe
here I didn't die again p didn't play
that well he letting him a little bit
back into the game here
black resins gem that wasn't that wasn't
as clear as it should have been when
like he I'm really totally winning and
somehow it got good unclear after this
move which was a good practical chance
at at least a completely muddied the
waters here now f5 f5 is good it just
took me too long how long for 30 seconds
that was bad mf5 I mean this is maybe
not even the best move but it is making
things a little bit easier the computer
just takes and place this and says I'm
winning but you know that's not so easy
for a human player it still looks a
little bit like black has something at
least it looks a little bad but he still
has those wacky pieces mmhmm yeah maybe
actually I've done jet that but this is
good them it is good though 95 I think
this is actually a good way to play
something like that it leaves me with a
key advantage but here I should somehow
managed to to to cure this off pretty
quickly yeah okay shy with the check on
c5 is better check I was thinking queen
is seven actually and look see one
that's supposed to computer gives yeah
that's actually quite strongly if we
check here I will win one of the pawns I
cannot defend both of them yeah check
better okay i will probably I probably
keep something even here but he's kind
of getting getting back into the game a
little bit and it's equal material yeah
yeah not not better anymore and maybe
here again I don't know it was a bit bit
of a time scramble thing as well okay
hope you like the game thanks for
watching